it's now my privilege to sign the
Homeland Security Act Department of
Homeland Security will have nearly 170
000 employees
the threat of mass murder on our own
soil
will be met with a unified
effective response
so the Department of Homeland Security
DHS is celebrating its 20th birthday
which is a perfect opportunity to
rethink the whole concept of Homeland
Security and how to best provide it DHS
has grown into a monster child that is
massively expensive incredibly
ineffective and reliably destructive of
basic civil liberties it's time to
abolish it and replace it with fewer
smaller and more accountable agencies